[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yay
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
do
do
do
[Music]
you
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about
[Music]
so
[Music]
classroom
[Music]
yo check this out
[Music]
i'm just gonna switch
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about
[Music]
go check this out
my
[Music]
chocolate
[Music]
oh
[Music]
two
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so i find it all incredible
he's looking at me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
in the party i feel my heart beat at the
bar right where she might
be break dancing on the sidewalk staying
away
everywhere
he's looking at me
wow
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
oh
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the razer keynote at e3 the
world's
biggest video games convention we have
got an insane
show for everyone today we have come a
long way here together
all gamers by gamers and today we're one
of the biggest
gaming brands in the world we span
hundreds of millions of gamers from pc
gaming
to console gaming to mobile gaming but
what i'd like to talk a little bit about
today
to kick things off is pc gaming
something
near dear close to my heart and pretty
much to talk about
the decade of the razer blade so
in 2011 we launched the world's first
true gaming laptop and this caused quite
a bit of controversy back then
because gaming laptops were not gaming
laptops in the true sense of the word
they were
gaming luggables back in the day super
thick
super heavy and the razer blade was the
first
true gaming laptop in the sense it was
super thin
super light and super powerful and it
ushered in
a new generation of gaming laptops
and since then over the past 10 years
the entire industry has moved to follow
in the footsteps of the razer blade in
2013
we launched the world's thinnest gaming
laptop
2016 we invented the world's
first thunderbolt 3 external gpu
in 2018 we launched the world's
smallest 15 inch gaming laptop
and since then we've now got the entire
razer blade family we've got the blade
self
13 we've got the blade pro 17
and of course we've got the blade 15.
and the razer blade has been both a
critical
and commercial success it's been called
the very
best gaming laptop in the world and
continues to win
accolades over and over again
and at this point many of our fans many
of the razer community
is asking what's next
so we go down and we talk to every
single one of our fan base four gamers
by gamers we talk to the press and one
thing that we've heard consistently
over the past couple of years is when
is razer going to make an amd
gaming laptop well
ladies and gentlemen i'm incredibly
excited to be able to announce
that we're now working closely together
with amd
and we've put the very best designers
and engineers
together with the top amd engineers and
what we've created
in a single line is the ultimate
amd gaming laptop and with that
we are bringing back the legendary
razer blade 14. how do we do this
how did we make the ultimate
amd gaming laptop well we took a look at
the 14-inch
gaming laptops today now many of them
have tried to follow in the footsteps
of the blade 14 that we created some 10
years ago
and many things have changed since then
in terms of form factor
many of the gaming laptops out there are
portable but what we feel
they could be thinner could be slimmer
now over and above in terms of gpus
there's been not much innovation don't
get me wrong they've got a great
gpu in there but they max out at the rtx
3060. in fact in terms of total graphics
power or tgp
they maxed out at just 80 watts and we
feel
it could go much higher with of course
the right materials and with of course
the right cooling thermal solutions now
as we talk about materials unfortunately
most of them still use
really non-premium builds now one thing
that we do at razer that all of you are
familiar with
is that we look at doing really premium
builds we've got
cnc'd machined um chassis we want to
make sure that you've got the best
possible no flex kind of a chassis
but many of the ones out there don't
have that and of course cooling
many of the 14-inch gaming laptops are
still using
solutions that we pioneered some 10
years ago at razer we've really pushed
it ahead we've
had vapor chamber cooling for years now
we're in the next generation of that
we've done that for laptops we've done
that for phones over and over
now in terms of having all this last gen
tech
many of them are still limited in terms
of the ports that they've got they've
got only a couple of type a ports a
couple of type c
ports so on and so forth and they've got
truly
truly uninspired keyboards they're using
single color backlit keyboards why
because they don't have space
or they don't have the imagination but
at razer we've got loads and loads of
imagination
and what do we want to imagine well a
whole lot of
ultras ultra what well ultra
powerful we want it to be ultra powerful
we want it to be ultra thin
we want it to be ultra fast we want to
have ultra connectivity
we want it to be ultra responsive and of
course ultra
ultra immersive that's a lot of ultras
to make the ultimate amd gaming laptop
but let's talk about how ultra powerful
the new razer blade 14 is now together
with amd
and razer we have designed and
engineered
in a single line the world's most
powerful
14-inch gaming laptop this is not
any normal gaming laptop that we're
talking about we're talking about the
world's most
powerful 14-inch gaming laptop
and to this end we wanted to pick one of
the most
powerful cpus on the planet today
and we've picked the amd ryzen 5900
hx this is truly an incredible
cpu we are talking about a hx class an
extreme
class amd processor and it's an unlocked
processor unlike many of the other
laptops out there using the
hs class processors we are using a hx
class
unlocked processor a zen 3 mobile
processor
in a cutting edge 7 nanometer
level it's an eight core x86
cpu and it's got an up to a whopping
4.6 gigahertz of power
this is an insanely insanely great
cpu and joining me here today talking
about this
partnership to make the ultimate
amd gaming laptop is jason banter
vp of product management of amd
razer is known for some of the most
innovative gaming laptops
in the industry razers has established a
design
quality and performance standard that is
second to none
that's why we at amd are excited to
partner with razer
for the first time bringing ryzen the
world's
best mobile gaming processors to the
razer laptop lineup
engineers from both companies partnered
together
start to finish to bring the best
components the best performance
and the best experience together in the
new razer blade 14.
the new blade 14 features an unlocked
ryzen 9 5900 hx processor
enabling elite gaming performance on a
thin and light notebook
with amazing battery the 5900 hx
delivers
eight cores and 16 threads of zen 3 core
performance
a max boost clock of up to 4.6 gigahertz
quickly dispatches workloads reduces
latency when gaming
and performs 3d renders at breakneck
speeds
the 5900 hx also doubles the l3 cache
size
compared to the 4000 series this massive
on-chip memory is
vital to unlock the full performance of
discrete graphics for gaming
and all of this is based on 7 nanometer
process technology
the amd ryzen 9 hx series was designed
to deliver the most
immersive gaming experience you can get
in a laptop
with zero compromises from all of us at
amd
congratulations to men and the entire
razer team
for outstanding execution on this
project
we are proud to be a part of this
generation
of razer blade laptops and look forward
to expanding these opportunities
for gamers in the future thank you very
much jason
so that was jason of amd talking about
our partnership
but the cpu of course while we've picked
one of the most powerful in the world
is just half the equation what's on the
other half of the equation
well the gpu we've picked one of the
most
powerful cpus in the world and we've
also picked one of the most powerful
gpus and we're talking of course about
the nvidia
geforce rtx 30 series now our engineers
and nvidia we've been working together
for many years we've been optimizing it
we've got the best
gpus in the world with nvidia
they've got up to eight gigs of vram and
one thing that we did
is that we've managed to push the total
gaming power
up to 100 watts of power we're not
talking about 80 watts that everyone
else is doing
we've pushed it all the way to the limit
up to 100 watts of
tgp and it's something as small and thin
as a 14 inch form factor now of course
we start with the rtx 3060.
it's a great gpu that's what everybody
else
is also using but we wanted to start
with that
now over and above our thermals guys
said
you know we're crazy at razor
we're the mad scientists we can take it
a notch
further so what have we done well
in the new razer blade 14 we've got an
rtx 3070 option
that's a truly powerful gpu
matched with a truly powerful cpu
but we're razer we want to take it up to
11.
we're going all the way up to the moon
and what we've done
with the new razer blade 14 is that we
have now
added as an option a crazy
and insane rtx 3080.
imagine that the most powerful gpu
on the planet with one of the most
powerful cpus on the planet
it's truly truly powerful and of course
joining me here on screen today from
nvidia to talk about
how we've put this crazy rtx 3080
into an ultra thin form factor of the
new razer blade 14
is matt vp global geforce marketing at
nvidia
on screen thanks min for inviting us to
present at your event
once again we're excited to partner with
razer on the development and launch of a
blade laptop
this time the all-new blade 14 powered
by geforce rtx
for the first time gamers can experience
an rtx 3070 and 3080 laptop
gpu in a 14 inch form factor it packs
incredible performance in an ultra thin
sleek design wherever you go you can
play the most stunning and graphically
demanding games
because the rtx 30 series includes
second gen rt cores that enable fast ray
tracing
enjoy realistic lighting reflections
shadows ambient occlusion
and more all of those make your games
more immersive
ray tracing is featured in many of
today's most popular games
nvidia dlss also has been widely adopted
by games
many refer to it as magical dlss
provides a huge boost of performance
using ai rendering and looks as good or
better than traditional methods
dedicated tensor cores built into the
rtx gpu do the ai processing
now in addition to the high frame rates
pumped out by the geforce gpu
nvidia reflex low latency technologies
give gamers the competitive edge in
their favorite games
nvidia reflex is now supported in seven
of the top 10 competitive shooters
but we're talking about laptops so
efficient power usage is incredibly
important
to making gaming laptops as thin and
cool and quiet as possible
that's where our max-q technologies come
in every aspect of the laptop
the gpu software pcb design power
delivery and thermals are all
optimized for power and performance
with the help of ai high performance
gaming laptops are faster and better
than ever before let me give you an
example dynamic boost 2
it automatically distributes the power
across the gpu
the gpu memory and the cpu for maximum
performance whether you're gaming or
creating we can't wait for gamers and
creators to experience the incredible
power
and the portability of the new razer
blade 14.
min thank you for your great partnership
thank you very much matt
and that is the ultimate
amd gaming laptop ultra powerful
and we just talked about it but
we've not just got true power it's not
just the world's most
powerful 14-inch gaming laptop let's
talk a little bit about how
it's ultra thin now how thin
have we gotten it well it's not just
ultra thin it is the world's thinnest
14-inch gaming laptop let it sink in
think about it i just said
this is the world's most powerful
14-inch gaming laptop and now
i'm actually saying it's also the
world's
thinnest 14-inch gaming laptop
we are talking about 16.8 millimeters
thin with a 3080
mind you it's 0.66 inches
thin and the reason for it is because
for the past 10 years we've been
bringing together the very best
thermals engineers on the planet they've
got all kinds of innovative solutions
they've been pushing the limits
and what we've got over here in the
razer blade 14
is the next generation vapor chambers
and we've designed this from ground up
we are light years ahead of the
competition
many of them are still copying what
we've done 10 years ago
and today we're 10 years here we're a
full decade ahead
we've designed the next generation vapor
chambers
in the blade 14. each of these tiny
little fans
have got 88 fan blades and we work with
fluid dynamic scientists
we made sure that every fan blade was
designed
from the ground up 88 fan blades what
does that mean
every single fan blade in our fans
is about 0.1 millimeters thin
we have designed fan blades the width of
a human
hair in addition of course we are using
t6 grade aluminum
cnc chassis you got to kind of touch it
to believe it
you've got to understand that's what a
razor blade
is about that premium premium quality
and of course that super durable
anodized finish ultra
ultra thin the world's thinnest 14-inch
gaming laptop so let's talk about
how fast it is ultra fast we've got the
fastest
14 inch display we've got two options
we've got an fhd 144 hertz and we've got
a qhd
at a blazing fast 165
hertz it's 100 dci p3
display ips grade it's amd
freesync premium and every single
display
is custom calibrated right out of the
factory
ultra fast now let's talk about
connectivity really quickly ultra
connectivity
lots and lots and lots and lots of ports
we're talking about wi-fi 6e we've got
bluetooth 5.2
now some of the gaming laptops are the
14-inch gaming laptops don't even have
space
to put a camera there
webcam it's a windows hello
lots of ports we've got um on one end of
the chassis we've got a type a we've got
a type c
gen2 the type c you know it's a gen 2
charging it's got a display port
uh in addition to that we've got hdmi
2.1 which
has an output of 4k 120 hertz
now on the other end we've also got
another type a and other type c we've
got
lots and lots of ports ultra
connectivity
let's talk about how responsive it is
ultra responsive
it's got a full anti-ghosted keyboard
we've pioneered this many many years ago
now one of the things i'm really proud
of is how buttery smooth this is like
melted butter
a precision touchpad is it's a beautiful
touchpad you've got to touch it
to believe it and unlike all the other
inspired keyboards
we've got a per key razer chroma
rgb keyboard it's a fantastic
keyboard it's an incredible keyboard
it's got beautiful key travel
you got to try to believe it this is a
legend by itself
it's ultra responsive and now let's talk
a little bit about how immersive
the new blade 14 is and what we've got
incorporated inside this is thx spatial
audio giving that
beautiful spatial surround sound all
around you
and of course we're using it with upward
firing speakers
you know that's a truly truly great set
of speakers
and at this point of time i'm sure most
of you guys watching
some of you guys may be skeptical we've
made it so powerful
we've made it so thin we've packed it
chock full of all kinds of features
this is like a laptop which is 10 years
in the future
what have we compromised and at razer we
do not compromise you'll know it if you
own one of our
blade laptops we do not compromise and
some of you may suspect
we may have put a really tiny battery in
there
absolutely not because on a single
charge
the blade 14 runs for up to 12
hours that's an insane level
of battery life in the blade 14. now
the team has put together a video a
quick ad to kind of show it to everyone
i'm sure you're excited to see it
and let's show it for everyone here you
go
this is what i'm made of this is for the
throne in the kingdom
the king's here dealing freedom do i die
do it now if you believe it
you reap what you sow every season yeah
every time
i am
and at this point of time i'm sure all
of you would like to see the actual
real thing this is not a figment of my
imagination this is not a figment
of the imagination of a gamer out there
but here it is
the legendary razer blade 14
back in flesh or back in cnc aluminum
you can see it's ultra ultra thin
imagine if we've got
a hx class cpu in there we've got a 5900
ryzen of course we've also got a 3080
nvidia geforce gpu
all in an ultra thin 16.8 millimeter
foam factor it's super super thin all
right i'm sure you guys would like to
see
the display this is a
165 hertz display
as you can see it's just truly
truly beautiful and yes there is a
webcam all right so check it out
and it just sounds beautiful so
this is the new blade 14. it's so
compact
packing a 3080 imagine that and really
quickly to take us through
this this is the world's most powerful
14 inch gaming laptop it's ultra
powerful it's ultra thin
it's the world's thinnest 14-inch gaming
laptop just imagine i'm saying
that at the same time ultra fast
ultra connectivity look at all the ports
on both ends
it's got an ultra responsive gaming
keyboard and it's ultra immersive
you know you've seen the upward firing
speakers and all of this with 12
hours of battery life today
together with amd i'm incredibly excited
to announce
the ultimate amd gaming laptop
the new razer blade 14.
now at this point of time you want to
know the price you want to know
availability
well i'm sure with a product like that
you're probably quaking inside thinking
is this going to be a 5
000 laptop it's got all the insane
features it's got the most
powerful cpus and gpus right you know
is this going to be um a 3 000
laptop well ladies and gentlemen the new
razer blade 14
starts at just 17.99
when is it available well not in 10
years from now it's available
right now today by the end of this
keynote you can order it
and where can you order it well you can
order it online at razer.com
or at any of our global razer stores you
can check them out
and of course at leading retailers
globally you can check it out
right away today at just starting from
17.99
ladies and gentlemen the new razer blade
14
the ultimate amd gaming laptop
so that's the first product that we've
got today
and we've still got a big show ahead so
what's next
insanely small insanely powerful
and what am i talking about well it's
our all-new
usbc 130 watt
gan charger 10 years ago when we first
launched the razer blade one of the big
innovations that we did
was we went and redesigned the charger
10 years later
we're now really pushing the limits of
what we can do
with power so here is a traditional
power brick it's shipped in many of the
other gaming laptops out there
not a razer laptop but this is often in
many of the other
gaming laptops this is 130 watt
size of a power brick all right it's
almost three inches tall it's got about
six inches wide
how big is the new razer gan charger
or how much smaller is it is up to 59
smaller it's so tiny it can fit
in your pocket and it's not just smaller
it's also up to about 17 shorter
it's an incredibly incredibly small
charger so i thought you guys would like
to see
how small or how large the chargers are
this is a traditional
130 watt uh power brick
it's pretty big it's pretty heavy it's
something that will ship with your
traditional luggable kind of uh laptop
so how small is the raise again charger
boom it's just hiding behind it
it's just so tiny the same amount of
power
that is packing from 130 watts and this
is a 130 watt
charger and this is already considered
one of the smaller 130 watt charges out
there
you can see how tiny how small it is but
we've got another surprise
for all of you this charger can only do
one thing it charges your 130 watt
laptop or gaming laptop this charger
doesn't just
charge your laptop boom it charges up to
four devices simultaneously that's how
powerful that's how insane this product
is this is the razer gan charger usbc
130 watts of power
truly compact power here's the side
profile
here's the front profile you can see the
four ports two usb c's and
two usb a's truly compact power and
here's a perspective shot
truly we've designed this so that this
is the perfect
charger that you can buy it allows you
faster charging up to four devices
it's mobile and travel ready with global
adapter plugs
and in summary it's small enough to fit
your pocket charge up to four devices at
once
faster charging two times usba two times
usbc
mobile and travel ready and it's got
safer power
delivery features now what does it work
with
well lots and lots of selected devices
as long as it's got usbc and charging it
works with
a whole slew of razer blade laptops
apple macbooks
both the pro and the air windows laptops
like the
dell xps tablets smartphones smart
watches
and much more so is this 500
is it 300 well absolutely not the razer
gan charger
is just 179.99
you can pre-order it right now and we're
shipping within the next
30 days and you can buy it of course at
razer.com
any of our razer stores and at leading
retailers globally
this is the razer 130 watt gan charger
and you'll want to be making your
pre-orders right now because this
is truly the ultimate charger
next up pixel perfect
well a couple of years ago we launched
the razer raptor
27. what do we have with it with a new
razer raptor
well still a 27 inch form factor
it's got an ips display it's got a
beautiful qhd resolution
display now what we've done is we've
upped the refresh rate from 144 hertz
from the previous generation
to a faster 165 hertz refresh rate
in addition we've looked at how to
ensure that this carefree
adaptive sync it's not just
using nvidia g-sync but it's also
compatible
with amd freesync premium and we've got
one of
the best display panels in the industry
it's got a 95 dci p3 color space
hdr high dynamic range display
and something i'm really proud of is
that this is
the world's first thx certified
gaming monitor and we've worked really
closely
together with thx specifically with the
gentleman eric gamma
who's got decades of decades of
experience
in making sure that he certifies the
very
best displays in the market and joining
me on screen here today
is eric talking a little bit about our
partnership
hi there i'm eric gamer thx's director
of imaging technologies
i'm pleased to announce that thx has
certified its first ever
gaming pc monitor the newly refreshed
razer raptor 27 inch if you don't know
to become thx certified a monitor like
the razer raptor must pass
400 different tests run by the
certification team and me
the thx certification process makes sure
that the screen in question will perform
remarkably well
and our testing process includes
ensuring panels are lit consistently
colors are accurate and the image is
pristine and clear
the result is a stunningly good screen
that is good for fast-paced gameplay and
other challenging scenarios
more importantly thx certification plus
the razer raptors fast refresh rate of
165 hertz and one millisecond response
time
means the screen will keep with your
superhuman reflexes
if you're a creator the thx certified
screens like the raptor
have the added benefit of being a great
option for color grading
if you've ever worked on an artistic
endeavor and the colors you seem
look off compared to other screens don't
worry thx's certified screens and our
exacting attention to detail means the
razer raptor 27
serves as a benchmark for color accuracy
so your next project will look true to
your artistic vision
if the razer raptor is your main
entertainment screen
you're in luck because like all thx
certified screens the
razer raptor 27 includes our renowned
thx cinema mode
when it comes time to enjoy your
favorite blockbuster movie or tv shows
it'll look spectacular and pixel perfect
by correcting for color brightness
grayscale
and removing any excessive and unwanted
video processing
across the board the razer raptor 27 is
a superb entertainment screen
and we hope you enjoy the quality thx
certification brings
to the new razer raptor 27
thank you very much eric so that's eric
who's had
decades and decades of experience in
terms of making sure
that the very best displays in the world
are certified in accordance with thx's
highest standards and i'd like to talk a
little bit about
the new razer raptor 27.
it's got a forged aluminum construction
it's got a
beautiful construction it's got a unique
90 degree tilt that you can flex it and
have it positioned any way you like it
and
it's got lots and lots and lots of ports
it's got a beautiful integrated cable
management it's truly unique you can see
it from the rear
and when you touch the back of the new
razer rapture 27
it's got a beautiful textured fabric
backing now the display is optimized in
terms of software we've had
optimized gaming modes as well as
immersive cinema modes that you can use
and over and above of course it's
integrated
with razer chroma rgb so it fits the
entire
chroma rgb family with chroma as the
world's largest rgb platform you can
rest assured
the new razer raptor will fit
in terms of the entire desktop or battle
station
that you have now one of the things that
we've done to update the new razer
raptor 27
is to include visa compatibility
new razor raptor will allow you to use
monitor arms
with a visa compatible mount and this is
also backward compatible
with the previous razer raptor 27
and of course the mounts are sold
separately and i thought i'd share a
little picture of how
a triple screen monitor might look on
your desk
and it looks just beautiful
now that's fine i'm sure many of you
guys would like to see a video that
we've put together
for the new razer raptor 27 and here you
go
[Music]
all right so at this point of time let's
do a quick demo of the new razer raptor
27.
let's call up the raptor 27
all right here you go it's got a
beautiful beautiful screen it's forged
out of aluminum
it's a beautiful monitor let's turn it
around so people can see the um
integrated cable management as you can
see it's got a truly unique
cable management system all right let's
turn it to the front again
and one of the things that we've updated
the new raptor 27 is of course
the visa mount and with a visa mount now
you can have
a triple screen monitor there you go
boom um
display over here right on your battle
station if you turn it around
you can see how it looks it's truly
truly unique
and we're really excited to be able to
present this here today
the new razer raptor 27.
thank you very much so
in closing it's got an ultra fast
display we've upped it to 165 hertz it's
a beautiful display
it's got adaptive sync bear in mind it's
got both g-sync
and amd freesync premium
it's the world's first ghx certified
monitor
and it's a visa mount compatible sold
separately and it's got this
really clean ultra clean cable
management system
and lots and lots of ports
so how much is the new razer raptor
well you can pre-order right now at just
7.99
and we will be shipping within the next
30 days and of course
like most razer products you can order
it at razer.com
razor stores globally and leading
retailers
and also you can order the new visa
mount which is optional
at just 99 available today
at razer.com and at global razer stores
ladies and gentlemen the new razer
raptor
27 pixel perfect
so that's what we have today at
our razer keynote at e3 remember to join
us
after this we've got razor store live
every month we run this
we've got great new products that we
announced we've got giveaways
and we stream it live from one of our
razer stores
somewhere in the world but
that's not all we've got one more thing
to share with everyone
and it's safe social
and sustainable and what am i talking
about well
no other project hazel we announced this
at ces earlier this year and
at ces we had some truly truly
insane press coverage with everyone
out there saying when can i get a
project hazel will you make it
into reality and it wasn't just a press
we had resounding response from the
community every single one
asking us to make project hazel
a reality and many of you
had great ideas ideas for features
features to remove
we've heard your feedback we continue to
hear your feedback
on twitter on facebook ping us anytime
because we listen to all the feedback
for gamers
by gamers and what i thought i would do
today
is that i'd give everyone an update on
the project
because we are going to be making
project hazel a reality
so what kind of updates can we give well
when the pandemic first started we
converted one of our
manufacturing facilities to make
surgical masks today
we at razer make high-quality
certified surgical masks and we ship
them worldwide
we've donated over a million mosques
worldwide in the us
in europe in asia in africa etc
and we continue to do that high quality
surgical masks meeting the very best
standards
and what we've done is that we've taken
the learnings from that
the engineering the design and we've put
that
into project hazel so project hazel is
going to be using
replaceable n95 grade filters
we've now designed in a secure silicon
face seal
these are just some of the updates since
the last
time that we talked about this at ces
and we are going to make sure
that project hazel follows lab testing
with bfe rating that we've done for our
surgical masks
that's the safe aspect now what about
the social aspect what are we keeping
what are we not keeping
well first up the clear transparent
design we're definitely keeping that
we're also adding in interior lighting
so that in low light conditions you can
still see the face
of the project hazel user and one of the
big things that we've added
this time around is anti-fog coating
so we've got an anti-fog coating on the
inside of the project hazel
to ensure that the social function
still remains even during use
now what about sustainability now many
of you will be
aware sustainability is at the core of
what we do
over here at razer we care a lot about
the environment
one of the things that concerned us the
most when we were making these one-off
surgical masks was the sustainability of
um
the surgical masks well project hazel
has got a reusable mask design and
every single filter lasts three times
longer
than single-use surgical masks and what
i'm really proud to say is that
every filter uses 80 percent less
material
than traditional surgical masks now i'm
sure many of you
are waiting to try out project hazel and
i'm going to talk about availability
at the end of this but if you can't wait
to try project hazel out we've got
something really special for all of you
you can try
the project hazel filter online and see
how it looks on your face you can check
it out on instagram
check out razer and here's a quick video
to show how you can use
the project hazel filter on insta
now remember to tag us with your project
hazel filters because we will be
watching out for all of you and we might
have some pretty cool giveaways
for project hazel when the time comes
for shipping
so we've got a quick video to show you
the updates that we've made
since the last time we announced this at
ces here you go
[Music]
so i'm sure many of you are asking when
can i get one
when do they ship well with the insane
demand
that we're expecting for project hazel
we've put together a plan
so that we can get as many of these
units out to you as possible
we're going to have limited quantities
right from the get go so once we start
manufacturing
we're going to be doing sale by drops
we'll have all the database of everybody
who wants a project hazel
and we'll send you information once
there's units available
and our first drop is going to be
happening
early q4 we're still perfecting it
we're taking in all the beta feedback
you're going to see
units out in the field but the first
drop is going to happen
early q4 once we've got most of the
testing and certification done
and it's going to be available
exclusively on razer.com
and you can sign up now for all the
information at rzr
dot to backslash project
hazel so thank you very much for joining
us here today
at the razer keynote at e3 i'll be
seeing you guys soon
[Music]
goodbye
for a very special e3 edition
of razer store live we're at the razer
usa hq in irvine california this is my
first time here
i can't believe they let me in here i'm
just first of all my name is bravo and
rachel we're so excited to have you here
on this show uh it's gonna be fantastic
bravo you've done so many of these i
feel honored to be included we just saw
a whole bunch of product for men that
got me really excited and now we're
actually gonna get to go a little
hands-on with you so honor to be here
we're going to talk about everything as
you guys
know of course razer store live a
monthly show that
we've been enjoying for for many many
months now and that really as we always
say
razer's the only hardware company one of
the few gaming brands that puts together
a show for their community every single
month we're so excited
to have you joining us here and of
course
you